hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in the third part of his proma to
any future metaphysics Emmanuel Kant is
going to set out and discuss three
transcendental mental ideas that get us
in trouble they lead reason astray if
we're not careful and that's why we need
a critique of pure reason a Critical
examination by reason of itself as well
as of the understanding and
Sensibility and the third of these is
what Kant terms the
theological idea and as opposed to the
earlier psychological ideas and
cosmological ideas which were plural at
least certainly in the case of the
cosmological it's a little bit debatable
with the
psychological this is singular It could
only be singular and it's quite
different from the other ideas and the
discussion of it is quite short as a
matter of fact Kant is going to finish
by saying as the observations of the
critique on the pretentions of our of
transcendental theology are intelligible
clear and decisive I have nothing more
to add on the subject which means that
you know as opposed to all the other
discussions where we've been able to
just stick to the proma we probably do
need to look at the critique rather
briefly at least the section on the
ideal of pure reason for a few other
important nuggets or kernels of
information but let's look first at the
distinction that he is going to draw so
he tells us that the third
transcendental idea which affords
material for the most
important use of
Reason uh but then he qualifies this but
if pursued only
speculatively Transcendent and therefore
dialectical use of reason right so
there's another thing that we should
point out here that goes out side of the
scope of the
proliga so you know talking about a
purely speculative as opposed to
practical use of Reason means that we
can make a distinction here between when
this is going to be let's say
illegitimate and when this will actually
have some legitimacy to it within the
Practical sphere as we find out in later
works as for example the second critique
the critique of practical reason also in
uh arguably uh religion within the
bounds of reason alone what we have is
uh a different use of this ideal idea
ideal right so he goes on and he says
that this is the
ideal of pure reason not just an
idea but but something that goes beyond
it and if we want to understand what
that means we'll have to go to the
critique as we'll do
shortly first he's going to say this one
works differently than the psychological
and the cosmological ideas that we've
already looked at earlier in this part
of the work how so he tells us that in
the psychological and cosmological
ideas reason start from experience
right uh experience of things in the
world experience of our own capacity to
know to cognize to judge to do all these
sorts of things and it HS it goes wrong
by
exaggerating
here sort of you know heaping up raising
up their grounds the grounds of
experience why because it strives to
attain if possible the absolute
completeness full stendig kite something
we've talked about quite a lot the
Perfection the being brought to complete
fruition going Beyond experience of
their Series so could be a cosmological
could be a
psychological uh Series in this case but
what the ideas are doing you know for
example in you know conceiving of a soul
as some sort of eternal
lasting thing that is the locus of our
Consciousness right it's going Beyond
experience you can't experience a soul
in that respect or think about the
cosmological ideas we looked at the
different antinomies you know some of
these pertain to the nature of the
universe some of them pertain to
causality they also have to do with
moral ideas like Freedom right so
they're attempting to attain
completeness of the series which we find
in experience we don't actually find it
in experience of course but it helps to
make sense of our experience or at least
so we think right I mean these are
problematic these are part of a
dialectic what does the theological
ideal
do so he says that it breaks with
experience it's not about experience at
this point and from Mere con
Concepts mere
concepts of something else what
constitutes absolute completeness fendy
kite of a thing no longer a series but a
thing iing right a single thing in
general hence by means of the idea of a
most perfect perfect and again we have
you know uh fendig right
perfected uh a most perfect Primal being
now Primal
being right vas can mean being the UR
tracing it back further right so a
originary a beginning being right we uh
think of this idea by means of which uh
using this as a m right um a a a way in
which we can approach this so mere
concepts of what constitutes the
absolute completeness of a thing in
general thinking about the most perfect
thing no longer things in general it
goes on to
determine the possibility the Mite
whether something can be and the
actuality the
viite of all of other beings now you
know if you know your you know
metaphysics the history of it and
theology you recognize that what Kant is
talking about here is traditionally what
we refer to as God but it could be
anything else it could be spino's
substance it could be all sorts of other
things so long as it's taken to be the
absolute the Primal the final the best
whatever it is is
being so he goes on and he says that um
the mere presupposition of a being which
although not in the series of
experiences is
thought for the purpose of experience to
make sense out of our experience and for
the sake of
conceiving its
conception its connection rather
uh it's order and its Unity it's
B and inight
right when we are trying to make sense
out of our experience the vast
experience that we have con says that we
inevitably are going to gravitate
towards thinking about something that
you know lies behind the experience the
appearances of experience the
representations and is some sort of
Primal Unity that gives connection order
and unity to our
experiences right does this exist we
can't say that it does
exist that's where the transcendental
illusion comes in with this one a
dialectical illusion and Kant tells us
two things about this what is the
illusion making a subjective conditions
of our thinking into the objective
conditions of objects
mistaking what it is that our thinking
leads us to as as if it were the reality
of things so just because we wind up
thinking about some you know total Unity
some absolute being ah it must exist no
K is saying it doesn't exist and it's
something that we just come up with and
you know we project into uh reality he
also talks about making a
hypothesis necessary for the
satisfaction of our reason so this is a
hypothesis this uh ideal of pure reason
uh a hypothesis necessary for our reason
our faculty of reason to be satisfied uh
we make it into a Dogma a belief Bel
something that we buy
into and it tells us that this is a
mistake right we can easily expose this
dialectical
illusion and then he tells us the
observations of the critique are
intelligible clear and decisive I have
nothing more to add on the subject well
we should add a little bit more on the
subject taken from the critique and
there's a few things I'm not going to go
through the entire section the ideal of
pure pure reason but there are a few
things that we should signal so the
first thing this terminology idea ideal
right he says that um ideas are more
remote from object objective reality
than categories no appearance can be
found in which they may be represented
in concetto they contain a certain
completeness that no possible empirical
cognition ever achieves okay so we we've
already got that before in the prolom
but he says something that seems to be
even further removed from objective
reality than the
idea is what I call the
ideal by which I understand the idea not
merely in
concetto but in
individual that is as an individual
thing which is determinable or even
determined through the idea alone and
you know he gives some examples of this
talks about Plato a bit let's move on a
little bit
further um he is going to talk about um
the material of all possibility which is
supposed to contain op prior the data
for the particular possibility of
everything the idea of the sum total of
all
possibility right and he's going on a
little bit further he's going to say
this must be called an idea yell of pure
reason right and a little bit further
he's going to bring this we could say
into uh a context of traditional ways of
thinking about these things the object
of reasons ideal which is to be found
only in reason is called the original
being NS orari okay so that is pretty
similar to
theasin that we are talking about here
in the
proma um because it has nothing above
itself it's also called the highest
being NS suum and because everything
else as condition stands under it it is
called the being of beings NS antium and
then he goes on and he says this does
not signify the objective relation of an
actual object to other things but only
that of an idea to
Concepts as to the exist existence of a
being of such preeminent Excellence it
leaves us in complete ignorance we don't
know whether something like this exists
we can't say that with certainty we can
say reason wants us to buy into this but
this is why reason has to be very
careful and critical and engage in
indeed critique of itself and stay away
from from falling into the dialectical
illusion of these transcendental ideas
particularly this one the theological
idea or the ideal of pure
reason